ah so we're gonna just everybody panel
and ask them to introduce themselves
tell a little bit about this story I
have like one or two questions but
really this is that you asked me a
question for a chess game to you hi I'm
somber Swiss I was actually my name
registration friends I did my skin is
your new school in America remember
that's important is it to get a date
honey the Bison as inclusive
universities expecting the day
fortunately after the same PhD fine
sister and after this I pretty much went
more or less rightly California were in
97 so my Christine was at least yeah
that time so I went to my sister to my
sister invited me to join them and at
the critters that are I don't like I
didn't come cheap invalid they company
so they were from salt which I did it
already depends on it we're nation so I
joined one of the very first computation
that mercial is google 99 after they saw
this company failed for some reason I
then went to do my own comedy
distributed database which was my
superior we said the horizon software
and you realize
just have problems so very nicely that
they will not listen and I from ebay
today was the first time of year when
consumer web site that was fascinating I
am one of my clip of a person who
actually I in men yes cultures for
description of CDI test which is
precisely aligned invaders the glory
need a description thing after another
figure that you pay this guy a son that
work with those several me that I should
get some other guy and I wanted to say
which I did and this guy you gotta
convince me over lunch ready for the
starkest him and he promised into the
crack yo yo yo he also needed some money
and you have an office in two weeks all
of wish came true visually a coma after
lunch I said the event normal happy I
didn t give it and usually that was
between 15 on my first he had offices in
follow-up butcher young mechanic and we
will reply so i started out i live in
chicago with the university of illinois
mad from computer science brother grid i
also came out to California however I
was sure that I was going to be in
academic and
going to do nothing useful purposely i
wanted to be very academic so i was the
same early a PhD around the end of the
PhD as is natural in california could
involve the start of so i started to
start up with my advisor and my
officemate reason why you can plan your
perkins and so our year was is that
maybe like 10 years ago or maybe 15
years ago yahoo had organized the web
manually and then after that Google came
along and did this wonderful job
algorithmically saying kind of a
directory structure of the internet
we're going to have algorithms that it's
going to be better and it could be more
efficient and your life will be nice we
had a similar idea we thought we would
do something for your friends and social
like right now Facebook is essentially a
directory structure of Google+ is
directory structure Twitter just a list
and you can use something more and you
can make people better friends and I
think better people so we worked on that
he had some interesting technology we
got three great investors and then also
we had a conversation with Google at the
time it with Vika tundra we had dinner
with him and something very similar
happened soon after that or required
I've been at Google for almost two years
now so how do I Martin most of you know
me by now because I also drive this
event with all of the amazing speakers
that joined us today thanks to the
welcome and yes I I actually I spent two
years at stmicroelectronics freshly out
of college in in bristol in the UK right
after that I joined a startup called
mobipocket and this started was being
something that was a sprain chance and
some people you
orders that it was evil we want you to
make books electron so we work in two
thousand when he books were kind of hard
is a dead point and Microsoft invested
in the idea and we require near ebooks
on pjs at that point of Palm Pilots
pocket pcs and so on this run I can't
say successfully that it run that when
people were calling us that whatever
today was useless publishers we're
mostly hun is that ok what America was
evil that we will destroy culture what
they meant by that is that you are
disrupting the existing business model
but when we thought the publish articles
that the story culture and don't know
and we also have users we're involved
with a rock I remember in those days me
my ETA was not so easy we don't have
basic experience in those days we had
one sci-fi series that has this cable
news for some reason we can get the rise
of all University and we have complaints
people who write all the 15 volumes on
their shitty Palm Pilot PDA and they
were complaining where is all your CC so
there was engaging David but if it
wasn't a bad nothing like that and then
something like that happens the
smartphone so beat me sorry because
folks Eugene P games but funds if you
remember at that farm at screens even
smaller than my left and the first smart
and postage stamp-sized screens where we
was completely impossible it's
challenging the whole club it's
completely possible and one of those
though he has the early days and so you
have no so great business group but they
still believe this and well it didn't
happen that around 25 and as I have the
space crazy idea that they would change
their business model physical books to
electronic books and they started
Shakira for someone who had a technology
and happy to have the technology so they
were making the books of the five or
rather distribution weekend long the
reading technology of mobile devices so
the whole set there was not true
happiness of onset and we were happy
have to be acquired by amazon to
actually make the kindle it so nobody
ever talked about the most acquisition
experience which i talked to told you
guys it was cookie hello rose so I know
that only your dream of being requires
because II world being quiet is the end
of your son may great important work we
get money you wanted something else in
the company but it won't well don't 30
becoming the duty of the company because
you have
requirement you will do it becomes super
important backpaddle doesn't so you've
got timing I think a lot of like started
16 days on tonight like a lot of
companies in general a big we talked
about the Palm Pilot going away back you
had somehow we're seeing problems
created that but it still worked out
right a lot of situation so for yourself
what do you think right now you can
present we have time for that what trend
towards great applications question if I
knew there was a mi mus basil kisses I
mentioned this day this company is also
for only usual daily as well question
really well I asked the software was
great the concept of honey today is a
good fellow first 1000 2000 / is in
Morocco that was transactions and they
didn't want us today at first too soon
by the same token i soldered we solve
this see training CD that is insane and
thank you what we do is we let people in
church diesel power over possible and
the one thing i will say about finding
is its audience and if you donate right
you will fail and the best thing if you
are right is to check if you have users
so c20 was an awesome idea and it took a
year for us to realize
actually was not and he all right time
to do the cds and movies music very
quickly so the one thing about save our
family is irregular just change if you
have a sense that the man is on track
for your product to let you soon I just
change there's a time for everything and
if we recall your host or a binding
destroy so you talk about your advisor
so having advisory kinda can finish to
you go director shuttle services my
questions would you have on that
direction after your facials it out here
and it how do you suggest you guys find
that person that invited into that kind
of experience seasoned yeah question I
think the most important thing for
people you work but inside and you've
done occasionally you know it takes a
long time so I had done a long time work
with my advisor also my office me
started on the exact same day we went to
all the house visits for graduate school
at the same time like don't these people
for about seven years and I think that
more than anything else is having
reliable people that you can come up
it's really important because there's
lots of times where it will be in
conflict essentially it's a changing
landscape people come in with different
opinions if you don't have a successful
ways and resolving these different
opinions this conflict then I can just
start over just fall apart so being able
to do business people that know very
well you work with in the past is
fantastic also related to that my
advisor two thumbs artist for which I
would highly recommend this is your
first sort of then employ you're working
with
it's not the first art I think there's
certainly a trend investors notice this
is that the investment companies that
are having one of their founders we've
had a successful exit before just work
on or unsuccessful put an extra yeah
it's just seeing their choices though
you're 19 player is obviously not a bad
thing but there's a really interesting
blog by Joe Kraus she's a partner equal
mentions oh stop stop Oh earlier is that
it good things you know your belt but
the trend is successful run over and
that they often followed those numbers
so even for yourself wedding who have
been successful lastly it's a great way
to learn that boy Martin my question is
since these two guys over here open
Valley and they started their face
drummers there what do you think about
for these guys to name to go to Silicon
Valley his name brands like what's your
recommendation for end up stranded in
here um so first i will quote my former
boss at every pocket who famously said
that he was stupidly tired of having
planted somebody in paris and he said
out of himself so i can i can say it and
that wasn't you asked and thank god
things have changed and he was talking
specifically about the bureaucracy and
I've seen a study last month where
someone study of your facility with who
will be ejected European
okays scar to start up and surprisingly
that sudden said something that caused
was number one bureaucracy was
personally I prefer parish to the signal
valley but that's super personal opinion
and I guess many of you here to the
swell like layers one month in your lane
that is lot going on there London's and
passed a first artist so I definitely
think there's a lot to do here in Europe
will be more still like English is that
it's it is said to be easier to get
financing and especially serious on a
single second round I'd say in the city
of knowledge with investment private
investment is more than what their
vision the other side since information
I also heard it wasn't true because
competition was fierce but those
available be seeds so community and the
Palladium engineers they could were here
and there is something to be said about
going to the ballet for for the
experience the PCC environment and the
innovation bills other starters in the
ends of it's your choice but i don't
think that attaches yes I'm gray and
working on
you guys around high school it's just be
have a question said that the failure
rate you will probably find favor face
for a favor we have to say on purpose 30
seconds the second started the attention
of ec and say nice story about expelled
night school ever again everything I
think I succeeded in fail there's no
reason that I don't think be seized it's
not the thing I was like most surprised
and maybe I shouldn't be surprised by
this at all is that they were all really
smart all the bcs i talk to you i was
impressed by them they are more on like
the people side of things and they don't
always understand the intricacies of the
technology but they really are experts
at the field they've had a lot of long
track record of being good at what they
do i think what they noticed is that
people we succeed continuing to succeed
maybe this is not like really an insight
but they're not they're not going to be
won over by some story or some
background they really want typical
things that you need to see before
investing in a business what are the
backgrounds of the people what's their
track record did they have like the
skills to execute on this do they have a
vision well their vision like make money
how will they exit I mean they're
looking at basic things and I would
focus on these basics before you think
about any way to I guess it's a game
system and ways when I said about
failure is no that fader is good but
he'll failure is regarded regarded as a
sigma you fail you're a failure you know
that is not the case you can talk with
people who are serial entrepreneurs they
tell you I know this and piston
this as well and so you all said how'd
it go quite opaque but now i'm doing
this and it's great it's great and the
fourth thing may might have seen you
look at someone like well the famous
example is richard branson kids so many
shitty businesses before he actually
started in the recording business and we
had success there because one part is
that actually became successful and from
there he went on to part two to view the
whole the whole rest of the Virgin
Empire so the message was just feeling
is not a thing painting is experience I
shrugged our relationship you need to
take those all the smoke away so the
human ego or like number one advice we
show producer sonic experience it all
starts in my head it's going to be very
different in my experience it was
believing in what we did and stick
matures against all odds which usually
you are told not to do you're told to
play hard and DHL and so we had all
these people telling us how badly where
and how useless our product was and how
he was going to destroy the earth and
whatever and and we still get kept going
so we kind of knew that ebooks were
going electronic one point to climb
anyway that was a live inside knowledge
and we sucked it yeah what you said
resonates a lively just to add extreme
optimism in the face of high probability
of failure is very important but I think
Murray it's okay though I think you
actually need these two mindsets my my
personal advice for will be launched
sooner whatever you're planning on
launching you need to get it out there
sooner and this is really easy advice to
ignore because there's always good
reason
not the launch there's plenty of good
reasons not to watch but we should
launch soon whatever you're planning it
if you haven't launched yet this is a
really bad situation because you don't
have any feedback on how you're doing so
watch what Michael said before is a big
movies work with amazingly enough salt i
mentioned overall he was my best friend
in pretty rough shape we've seen that
many relationship and by for something
sodala successful one I saw the best
acquaintance actually learn at lunch and
I was extremely were particularly for
people and nation to cope well that
helps you go through all little problem
that same destination you're a depressed
you're going to an option or into
insanely hard away and all of those
safety cap good friends in your face
hello yes I work in an organization of
clients it's a slow ass Anders Anders
and I do have a question about timing
and your two examples are practical stay
on your case you say that you had to
believe in what you did and then
actually we waited very much at work and
about the question for timing is that
yeah but sometimes it's not excited so
when you see doesn't work it should just
get out as sensible take I think it's
often the question for startups
Halloween portal when we even my is this
and how
actually somewhere there's no market
such a good question i answered recibo
happy ramadan name Parker on the funding
so if you do your first from the
mounting the bank account that's a
reality check so I'll get that the jab
at very objective with really really
home to get up on some cities and so
much patient is it really hard to decide
that it's not working and sent to a
trust after omikami so in like is
funding I'm not going to say it wasn't
funny was it bro we were operating as
just for sale to a microscopic company
actually we were a maximum of 17 people
at the hands of the web bubble and she
late two thousand so like fall 2000 BC
said oh down we're walking out so
on we fire a second one we may shoot 15
engineers and from their own weekly sale
but small bits so other founders would
find some money and we started making
some money little revenue which was kind
of enough to get us to apply years
slow-paced say so we even have that
reality check time we are out of money
what do we do now in our case the real
reality check was that we had a search
not many those customers seem to be
pretty engaged in us they were being
customers they were being he averaged
eight dollars per per book so not not
penny's ten dollars for every book and
they were coming for more weeks did you
have enough of them we didn't have
numbers we watch it but those were in
those who managed to convince they were
comments they wanted more so that's not
what gets on we had a small variable
leaving and active customers hi auntie
media streaming video oh my gosh is one
for you I don't even tell you but
require this is a dinner with mice and I
wish it would be what exactly was your
company acquired because great minds
just great eugenia me everything you
know what was it that maybe we need your
precise recently got acquired by by
giants so in our days we had a very good
is it i should say let's be there only a
very foundation is it and we were lucky
enough to have civil people fighting for
us I think the reason my thing for us is
because they were afraid of each other's
houses and so that mother Katie because
we were clearly on relevant users will
overcome probably not and so I was
worried that somebody else will get us
and solicit II but when I wasn't point
out so that we never ever worked with
the Empire we always go to our business
product always Cecily always good
question i think one of the most
important things is that you need to
think about why you're doing this so
some of the advice I got early on diz
it's better to be a missionary
universitaria it's kind of like a funny
thing but if you're in it just for the
exit not not saying you shouldn't think
about that ever but if you're in it it
will be a kind of an unhappy person hi
personally I think this is true is that
you need consider things not just in the
context of business but in the con
so I and the reason that I worked on it
was you know because I believed in the
mission and I think you know
acquisitions have like a lot of
different factors going into it but
companies do recognize people who are in
a true passion I think a lot of the
times that's what they look for in
addition to passion for the users and so
I would my advice about acquisition in
general is keep your eyes on the true
target don't go don't even really big
about acquisition well in our case it
was working a match so Allison was happy
some chick faces at this idea that he
wanted his book business to become an
e-book business and that's something
that you promised his shareholders
because I was another fun with a
bookseller and everybody kind of have
this idea that physical goods one day or
the other specialty cultural goods are
going digital I measure from play I'm
just before if there's was difficult to
accept that we require by a giant and
don't you want to create a new starter
sure it's actually ok interesting
majority of founders and google acquires
and a lot of other people after starting
the majority episode stay and probably
if they let us have a lot of freedom so
you sort of have our own internal
so actually my start that was acquired
by hands on and what happened is I was
one of the first engineer at that
startup it wasn't the founder of the
first one Junior what happened is that
after the acquisition of course the
founders left as soon as they contract
allowed them to to lead it's always like
that we get these claws in the position
saying you have to stay for a year and a
half and you negotiate the clothes so
that is only half a year and then you'll
be as soon as you can the wide as always
what happens and then another asked me
to be the CEO that started bushnell was
a 60 year so that's not the reason I
state a couple of years as Amazon gives
a bad one of the challenge for me and
like that challenge Ivan Ivan came over
google I do something of a 50 French
developer relations so I seen a lot of
startups and i love the innovation that
I see energy of these out clear course
it's empty I can't say he owned a video
that my boss will actually watch and I'm
thinking about ok so do I want to do
something else I think the answer is
eventually I wrote but you know life is
pretty long and I'm very happy where I
am right now so the biggest difference
is are you contribute differences white
one is surprising one problem and so it
was surprising one is that I learned way
more google the night event the story so
to start up I learned very little about
very many things but overall wasn't a
lot like you added up all my learning to
do bucket it was just like a whole bunch
of random crap
a little bit about PR a little bit of a
marketing a little bit of a programming
a little bit of a database is little bit
about algorithms I feel like a Google
now i am working on something that I
care a lot about so I did my PhD I'm
working on algorithms now I
recommendation system the amount of day
if you have here is amazing I really
enjoyed it so I'm going to stay probably
for quite a long time the second thing
which is the obvious one is that I don't
have existential stress in my life
anymore ah hi I used to wake up and you
know worry about the company and about
the people were working there is that
you if I screwed up the company would be
over like you know you have it go in
someday tell these people you know route
early i'm laying you guys off that this
is a very stressful situation to be in
and baby it's exciting to but right now
I feel like a focus of what I do not not
like some abstract not some bad result
that will come from my actions this is
because I believe in the mission of
Google you know the organized the world
information make it universally
accessible and useful I really do
believe in this I think this is a good
thing for the world and has made the
world a better place and I don't worry
about Google's financial health either
so I can come in I can work towards that
mission and give you the kind of work I
enjoy doing every day thank you
gentlemen all joining us and you guys
all for coming today we really
appreciate
you